hi ich habe eine Frage und zwar stört es
nicht tierig wenn man immer als
Hausmeister Krause irgendwo angesehen
wird und immer nur mit dieser Figur
identifiziert wird und wird man nicht
auch total oft auf der Straße deshalb
angesprochen ja ich freue mich über die
Antwort danke
schön ja danke für die nette frage ich
kann dazu sagen Hausmeister Krause habe
ich 10 Jahre gemacht und da bin ich
natürlich oft schon wirklich fast mit
ihm verwechselt worden egal wo ich
hingekommen bin her Kuse wo ist denn der
Dackel und ich sicher sicher sicher ne
die Frage habe ich ja noch nie gehört
aber jetzt habe ich z.B wieder Tommy
gemacht mit der Pudelmütze und da bin
ich ja gar nicht mehr ko ey ich bin es
nicht mehr ich bin Tommy der Superbulle
im
Augenblick aber du wolltest ja damit
fragen ob das nicht im Allgemeinen so
ist schätze ich mal ich kann dazu nur
sagen wer den Arsch aus dem Fenster
hängt soll sich nicht wundern ne wenn
jemand den sieht und
ich denke mal die diese lustigen Seiten
dass man immer da angesprochen wird mit
den Sprüchen das kann man gut in Kauf
nehmen das heißt doch eigentlich nur
dass die Leute drauf reagieren das ist
wirklich gesehen haben das ist ja
eigentlich
gut